MILO BABIC: Little bit about
iStreamPlanet, who we are.
When you think
about us, you think
about that company that
takes a single broadcast feed
and then transforms that
for distribution for all
these different devices.
So if you pick up NBC Live
Sports Extra app, for example,
and you're watching Premier
League or you're watching NFL
or you're watching
NBA or Formula One
or any number of
different sports
that we support on
an ongoing basis,
we're responsible for
taking that broadcast
feed, conditioning,
inserting all the ads,
all the closed captioning,
providing all the security,
and the [INAUDIBLE] management,
encryption, and then
conditioning that stream, once
again, especially for different
sets of devices by creating
different playlists for all
those different devices.
And we do this on a
daily basis for something
close to about 200 linear
channels that we operate today
and approximately 250
different live events.
Anything from all these
premium sports or media
brands that you see
here on the screen.
So what's new in
the market space,
and why are we so excited to
be collaborating with Google?
And really, what
led us to Google?
I think it's hard not to notice
that all these announcements--
new exciting announcements--
about TV finally getting
transformed after
all these decades.
Saying the same stuff--
setup box, remote control,
very, very, very slow user
guide, and limited number
of channels or certain bundles.
And then all of
sudden what happens
is HBO announces they're
going over the top-- you can
subscribe, and you can watch all
the great content HBO produces
and creates for us
live and on demand
and you don't need a
cable subscription.
And then many others
followed to this.
Sling TV, which is
a product of a dish,
creates what we call a
skinny bundle-- unbundles
a bunch of channels.
Creates a pretty compelling
bundle that probably 80% of us
use on a daily basis and
makes it available to us
over the top on any device.
And many others.
Now, as exciting as
that is, there really
are three big challenges.
And instead of talking
about these challenges,
I'm going to tell
you a little story.
It is 2010 and
we're getting ready.
It's the end of
January 2010, and we're
getting ready to stream
the Vancouver Olympics
for the first time in HD.
And we had 28 different live
sources coming all the way
from Vancouver, NBC,
and the Netherlands
because we had three different
broadcasters that we were
working with, as well as
the Canadian folks-- we
had six channels from Canada.
And I remember going back home--
it's about 3:00 in the morning
after one of those long, long,
long, long days-- turning
on my Cox cable and there
was only 16 HD channels
at the time.
We were running 28
of these channels
for 18 days and about
3,000 live events
covering every single
second of the games.
But really the point I'm
trying to make is about a week
prior to the Olympics,
we get a call
from two more broadcasters.
And when they told me, they said
Milo, we need 10 more sources.
And how much is
it going to cost?
And I said, I can't do it.
They said, what do you
mean you can't do it?
We'll pay you $100,000 for
each one of these sources.
I said, if you pay me
$1 billion I can't do it
unless I take away from
hardware, software, and all
the cable and everything
else that we have allocated
for our current customers.
It would take me
approximately six weeks
to procure the equipment.
It would take me
another four weeks
to get everything cabled up,
powered up, and turned on.
And then probably another
two to three weeks
to get everything integrated
with end-to-end workflow.
And in the meantime, the
Olympics will be long gone.
So needless to say,
we did not end up
providing services for these
two additional broadcasters.
But it left an impactful
thought in my mind
that we didn't have scale.
Not only did we not have
scale, but we did not
have ability to elastically
scale based on demand.
The complexity of workflow
was too high, too long.
We took too long to
provision things.
And all these
different hardware--
all these different
appliances that it
takes to organize
this premium content
and delivery across
these different devices--
they're very expensive.
Each one of these boxes
are $20,000 to $30,000
and you've got to integrate
them and the cabling
and time and everything else.
Obviously, that
was a huge problem.
So what we did is we set
on to solve this problem.
Part of the vision was how do we
move all this complex workflow
all inside the software
so we don't have
three or four different
appliances performing
different tasks, we don't
have an enterprise bus
that tries to connect all
these different systems?
How do we lower the
cost of doing all this?
And how do we scale dynamically?
So if it's Olympics
time and we need
to go-- for example,
for Rio, we're
going to have something
close to 100 different feeds.
Now, on a regular day, our
customer, NBC, for example,
uses something like
16 to 20 feeds.
But during those
18 days, they're
going to need an
additional 100 feeds.
How do we turn them
up, spin them up?
They operate for about 18 days--
process every single second
of the games.
And then on day
19, they go down.
They disappear.
And best of all, the customer
only pays for those 18 days
that they used.
So what we created
we call Aventus.
It's our platform.
It's our product.
It's the world's first
fully-distributed product
built 100% for a cloud--
solely for a cloud.
The distributed
architecture allows
us to acquire schedule,
acquire content, process
all the content, all the
bits, insert the ads,
process all the
closed captioning.
In case there's
any issues with any
of the parts of our
workflow, our system
will automatically detect that.
It will give you the
data in real time--
what's happening
from a moment we
get the content to
the moment content
gets delivered to the end users.
And then if there's
any problems,
we're going to use all of
this wonderful big data
that we gather and solve
the problems on the fly.
And that's what we
do today with Aventus
and that's what we
use for our customers.
Now, why was Google
interesting to us?
I think Chris from
[INAUDIBLE] and gentleman
from [INAUDIBLE] did a
great job talking about I/O
and all these sorts of things.
So I'm only going to
focus on the networking.
About nine months
ago during this show
was called
International Broadcast
Conference in
Amsterdam, we probably
met with about 40 to
50 different customers.
And the messaging was very
loud and clear to us--
how do we take
advantage of Aventus
and all these great products
that you guys have built?
But we need it in Australia.
We need it in Singapore.
We need it in Japan.
We need it in Frankfurt,
all over in Europe,
and Latin America.
The Olympics are coming
to Latin America.
How do we take advantage
of all these capabilities
around the world?
And then lastly,
how do we do this
without spending a
vast amount of money,
egressing and ingesting his
content into the network?
This is a very,
very big problem.
So when we open up these
discussions with Google,
it's great to know that search
and advertising and everything
else runs on this platform,
which we can attest to it.
In fact, I'm going to
break this pattern.
I'm actually going
to show you a demo--
the actual demo of the product.
But it was really,
really cool knowing
that we can ingest gigabits
of gigabits of content--
I'm talking about hundreds
and hundreds of channels that
are live linear events--
into the Google Cloud
without actually
paying any extra cost
if we're inter-carrier partners,
which was of huge value
to us and our customers.
So today, we run a number
of different channels.
We're actually in
a beta mode today.
In about 30 days, we're
going to be in production.
We're looking to launch
just over 500 channels
over the next 12 months and do
about 3,000 live events a month
on average through a
Google Cloud Platform.
But enough talking about this.
Let's go into some
demos and some fun stuff
here and actually show
you some video going
through Google Cloud Platform.
So I'm going to swap this thing
out, if that's OK, real quick.
MODERATOR: You've gotta love
it when the CEO gives the demo.
MILO BABIC: That's
what it's all about.
You've got to show
people what we're doing
and why we're excited by Google.
Let's see, there we go.
So what you are
looking at right now,
this is our very,
very simple interface.
I mean, we stole the
idea from you guys.
Google search box.
There's just one
box, very simple.
There's no 30 menus
and sub-menus.
So I'm going to create,
actually, a new channel.
I'm going to call
this a GCP demo.
And sources, we have
various sources.
I'm going to pick the
NBC sports network.
Sports is always more
fun than the news.
Out of our cloud video router.
So we also have a capability
to route all these video feeds,
and then through our
cloud video router, which
is a part of our product, we can
send this to any Google Cloud
locations around the world.
I'm going to leave
it at default preset.
The language, I'll have
Aventus reconfigure all that
automatically for me.
And I'm going to enable--
so instead of typing
all this data, I have NAB demo.
And I'm going to click
on Start channel.
So now what happens
here is-- what I've done
is essentially I've
created a JSON payload.
This says, go ahead
and find this source.
Subscribe to this
particular source.
Do this particular encoding
configuration on it.
Dynamically determine what
kind of source comes in,
what kind of outputs can
we create out of that,
and then create the HLS
package and HLS format.
And that JSON file gets sent
out to our cloud orchestration
layer, and then our
orchestration layer,
what our orchestration layer
does, it unpacks that and says,
OK, well, now I have
this kind of encoding,
I have these different bit
rates, this kind of packaging,
this is where my source is.
I need this much computational
power from Google.
Well, it's too fast.
I can't even finish my speech.
I'm sorry.
Your cloud works really well.
So what it does, it says, I
essentially need this much CPU,
I need this much storage, I need
this much egress bandwidth out.
In this case, through
Akamai, we have not
done a work yet [INAUDIBLE].
Apologies for that.
We should probably
talk afterwards.
But we're publishing all
this content to Akamai,
and it essentially creates
this channel on the fly.
And what you're seeing
here is actually a preview.
So we're generating a preview
about every five seconds.
We're generating a
preview of what's
coming into the Google
Cloud environment
where we're actually
processing in real time.
And what you can see
here, we're creating
seven different layers.
It's 720p output, 64k audio.
By the way, everything
that we run in Aventus
is based on APIs.
Even our own UI runs and
calls the same sets of APIs
to create this
type of experience.
And then I can perform all
sorts of slight insertions,
add insertion, do
all the blackouts.
I can check my channel health.
So we'll collect all
the data in real time
and expose that to you.
Everything from the moment
we ingest the content
to the decode, encode,
packaging, encryption,
publishing, ad
insertion-- we will
track everything in
real time and use
that data to fix problems.
If there are any
issues, and it seems
like there was one
issue with something--
I thought I saw a little
blip on ingest-- alerts
will pop up automatically
in real time.
If there's any problems
that cannot be fixed,
Aventus will automatically
self-heal them by failing over
to a different virtual instance.
And at the end of the day,
once everything plays,
we can go here.
And let's go ahead and
see some real video.
If we can switch to this screen.
By the way, I can perform the
same sets of tasks-- great,
thank you, guys-- perform the
same sets of tasks off my iPod.
It looks like there's
some source ingest issues.
Let's see.
If we click on this, we should
be seeing video here shortly.
Those are the source issues
that we're seeing in alerts.
So this is actually
a source that's
getting routed from Stamford,
Connecticut, all the way
from ABC's facility, down into
Las Vegas to the Google Cloud.
So it looks like we're
having some source ingest
issues coming from Stamford.
So that's the video playing--
apologies for source ingest
issues.
But if you can switch me back on
the previous screen-- actually,
I will show you here.
You can see that Aventus
has already detected that.
So if I look in my
alerts, it's going
to tell me lost incoming
stream data coming in,
and that's why it's
having performance issues.
So anyways, that's the demo.
Apologies for a source
that's coming in.
It is coming like that from
Stamford, Connecticut, all
the way through us.
So we're having some
playback issues on that,
but that's
essentially giving you
no idea how quickly we can stand
up a channel, how quickly we
can deploy this.
It takes us about 15
minutes, and we can deploy
Aventus anywhere around the
world at any Google Cloud
locations.
And we can stand up one, 10,
50, or 1,000 of these channels,
all within 15 minutes.